if you love all the birds and trees all
the fishes in the Seas if you think
videos of pets is as good as it gets
this segment is for you we hope your
furry dreams come true it's time to
celebrate Graves and I'm a friends
yes it's time for Greg's animal friends
cause he's not here doesn't mean we
can't have some fun showcasing furry
friends too okay cat what do you got oh
yes all right I don't want to ruin it
because there's no way to explain this
you just have to see it so let's roll
the tape
all right see horses and then there's
also people dressed as Horses
living out their horse dreams now some
people might have a problem with this I
think it's great because you know what
that took a lot of like passion and
there was many steps that occurred
before you're actually out there dressed
as a horse with the horses like you have
to make the costume you have to like
find a guy with horses who's cool with
it uh and that requires a lot of passion
and dedication and a lot of people might
think that's weird but guess what these
people don't care because they're that
happy they're identified as Horses I
don't know we should all strive okay to
be this happy and dedicated to something
like I love my husband but I don't know
if I'm as dedicated to him as these
people are to their horse dream
they've definitely done more paperwork
I know a guy in Enumclaw Washington who
did something similar to this and it
didn't work out too good
this didn't work out good either because
that horse thinks it's Mating Season
yeah
so he's kicking the leg and the the guy
in the back said my turn to be in the
front like no you're good
no seriously this one means he's not
stopping look Mr hands kicking back like
no means no no means no
I also I wonder how long do they do this
for is it an hour is it five hours every
day and did they pay for the privilege
yeah probably okay well they didn't pay
for the costume because that was a blank
if you're gonna do it do it right that
was half past three yes all right Jeff
what do you got I brought in a nice
little thing I'm a big sports fan but if
you watch sports you'll realize that
America's falling behind even in sports
sports a little bit baseball the best
players are Dominican Venezuelan uh
Mexican I think it's all over you know
in every sport and every sport you find
but I have got something to present to
you something where we can take back
Sports in the USA roll it
snake hunting
watch this guy great technique
gripping the head
it's dangerous sure but finally I'll be
good at something you could do that yeah
I do I'll give it a shot we start a
minor league system we work our way up
how'd that work out for the crocodile
guy well you know he was he's part of
the one of the forefathers of these kind
of white sports
you probably have one of these snakes I
do
um which is this is funny this makes me
laugh this that looks like a pet that
somebody decided to because no one with
any right mind leans on all muscle a
snake is basically one long arm of
muscle and he just rolled in like get on
me get on me the snake's like I haven't
eaten in a month bro just give me some
water and put me back in my cage oh we
caught him live and listen don't talk
about the crocodile hunter that way okay
I'm still a little suspicious about his
death Stingray and his best friend was
filming it and then all of a sudden he
died and then he married his wife hmm
just asking questions just asking
questions those are good questions what
about your video do you got a video yeah
uh actually I don't have video I have
photos and I have some new additions to
my Zoo okay and since we have a tiny
host I will show off some of my tiny new
editions okay
now this those are my uh yellow tree
monitors and that's they decided to get
together that's my Dana Perino that
gecko is the size of a quarter they're
little tiny ones and they're coming
crazy that's the male he's blue and you
can slow it down because we're trying to
drag this segment out in the back so and
that's my uh whoever's back there
clicking it relax kid the now these are
Mana Mata Turtles and what's so awesome
about them and that one's eating fish
now we're going to the back okay is
Gutfeld here so but this little
hey
whoever's doing this is going to be in
my cage
go to the little tiny Dana Perino Gekko
I don't think they know what a gecko
okay if you don't you're racist I
think
black and smart
this this little tiny Dana right here uh
just like Dana has bright yellow hair
which is questionable whether it's
natural or not and then
they're called little day geckos and
they come out and they sit on your
Windows still all day and I have about
50 of them and I just let them loose
because if you have a bug problem
instead of using spray put these little
guys in there they're amazing and
they're awesome just don't have a cat
yeah
I have a Maine cat and the cat was
like thanks thank you very much and then
like that was like that was like a snack
yeah gecko problem I got rid of all the
Flies
Brad all right so this is a Canadian Pig
and he stands up to this black bear all
the other farm animals run away like
scared little chickens this Canadian Pig
says not in my house and scares off the
black bear so my message to America is
just find somebody who's got your back
like that Pig's got the back of the rest
of the farm because that is some that's
some courage right there to front up a
bear zoologist about this okay so Tyrus
Pig said
said a racial Epitaph the bear said oh
my God how dare you and he left that's
what that is I came here to forge and
make friends and the pig's like we don't
want your kind here
Iris and it's always a big-headed person
who ruins a party it's always the pig in
the room that ruins the party and like
because oh because pigs are different
than everybody else you know why because
they go all into everything they always
go too far the chicken lays the eggs
pigs give bacon that means the chicken
goes in it a little bit contributes and
the pig has to go all out and she had to
go all out and ruin the party it was
probably the Bears surprise birthday
party and she ruined it
I think you should give tours at the zoo
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else